der mobilfunkstandard 5g wird alles
bisher dagewesene in den schatten
stellen und zwar nicht nur bezüglich der
datenrate sondern auch in sachen
kapazität und latenzzeit und somit also
blitzschnelle reaktionen im netz möglich
machen damit werden blockieren das
internet der dinge oder das autonome
fahren vollkommen neue dimensionen
erreichen klicks um science fiction die
gibt es täglich spannende science videos
nur wenn er den kanal abonniert verpasst
er kein video herzlich willkommen vielen
dank für diesen spannenden themen
vorschlag den er mir per whatsapp
geschickt habt der link zu meiner
persönlichen nummer der findet sich
unten in der beschreibung 10 gigabit pro
sekunde also 10.000 megabit pro sekunde
soll die übertragungsbandbreite des
neuen mobilfunkstandards 5g sein
das sind wirklich unvorstellbaren
geschwindigkeiten denn das höchste der
gefühle sind bei den derzeitigen lte
netzen im regelbetrieb 300 mbit und also
megabits und dieses meisten smartphone
nutzer haben gerade mal tarife mit
maximal 50 mbit nur um uns noch mal
richtig deutlich zu machen
mit 5 g könnte man einen film rund 600
mal schneller laden als mit den besten
dsl anschluss doch nicht nur diese fünf
die datenraten habe es in die 5g soll
vor allem die laufzeit der signale im
netz verkürzen und zwar im vergleich zur
lte um den faktor 48 die sogenannte
latenz also signal verzögerung liegt
dann bei nur noch einer millisekunde
oder weniger in der praxis bedeutet das
anwendung die über das internet
gesteuert werden haben so dermaßen kurze
reaktionszeiten dass sie nicht mehr vom
menschen wahrgenommen werden können
vorbei sind verzögerungen bei gesprächen
bei denen man sich deshalb ständig ins
wort fällt total nervig ist das und das
ist nicht nur für gespräche oder gamer
sondern allem fallen für die industrie
total spannend denke man autos die in
echtzeit kommunizieren oder aber
mensch-maschine-interaktion also an
virtuelle und erweiterte realität vr und
argumente trelle ti
so könnten beispielsweise
servicetechniker die benötigten
instruktionen über daten brillen
eingeblendet bekommen
bei der ganzen 5g geschichte hat die
bundesnetzagentur eine wichtige aufgabe
sie ist dafür verantwortlich dass das
frequenz vergabeverfahren objektiv und
transparent abläuft dazu heißt es auf
der webseite
die
digitalisierung schreitet zügig voran
damit einher geht eine wachsende
nachfrage nach hohen datenraten bei
zunehmender mobilität der verbraucher
für zukunftsfähige digitale
infrastrukturen sind den
marktteilnehmern geeignete frequenzen
frühzeitig und bedarfsgerecht
bereitzustellen damit soll ein schneller
flexibler und bedarfsgerecht hat 5g
rollout in deutschland ermöglicht werden
doch welche technik steckt dahinter zum
einen muss für fünf geht die anzahl der
antennen deutlich erhöht werden
in einer zelle könnten sich dann mehr
antennen befinden als nutzer der
fachbegriff für solche antennensysteme
heißt übrigens messe multiple input
multiple output kurz messe mimo zudem
werden die netze für 5g dichter werden
müssen so dass der mittlere abstand
zwischen den basisstationen deutlich
kleiner sein wird als bei lte für die
datenübertragung müssen dann höhere
frequenzen genutzt werden denn das
derzeit genutzte frequenzspektrum
zwischen 0,8 und 2,6 gigahertz ist voll
konkret geht es um den bereich von 6 bis
300 gigahertz und wird somit auch als
millimeterwellen technologie bezeichnet
ein weiterer punkt ist die dezentrale
organisation der mobilfunknetze das ist
für die latenzzeit sehr wichtig konkret
bedeutet das dass bestimmte daten aus
einer funkzelle direkt in der
dazugehörige station gefiltert und
verarbeitet werden und eben nicht weiter
verschickt werden für den technischen
voraussetzungen heißt es von der
bundesnetzagentur
wir gehen mit unseren versorgungs
auflagen an die grenze des
wirtschaftlich zumutbar und rechtlich
möglichen wir verpflichten leben
anbieter bis ende 2022 mindestens 500
stationen zusätzlich zu den auflagen für
straßen und haushalte für 5g aufzubauen
wir sprechen also beispielsweise bei
drei anbietern von 1500 stationen in
deutschland mit denen der neue
mobilfunkstandard eingeführt werden muss
außerdem müssen die anbieter jeweils
weitere 500 masten aufstellen mit denen
sie mindestens 100 megabit pro sekunde
in ländlichen regionen die versorgung
verbessern
fachleute sind sich einig dass lte noch
nicht mal richtig ausgereift ist und
sich so mit 1 5 g super netz langsam
entwickeln wird auf dem weg dorthin
könnte auch ein 4,5 die nets ein
zwischenschritt sein
zumindest das mobilfunknetz für den
mainstream wird wohl mindestens noch die
nächsten fünf jahre 4g bleiben da 2
und 20 rechnen expertinnen und experten
dann mit 15 g inseln für bestimmte
anwendungen die auktion der 5d
frequenzen ist laut bundesnetzagentur
jedenfalls für das erste quartal 2009/10
angesetzt ob dabei noch andere
unternehmen neben vodafone telekom und
telefonica für die frequenzen bieten
werden ist noch offen
bis ende 2022 müssen dann aber
mindestens 98 prozent der haushalte mit
einer datenrate von 100 megabit pro
sekunde versorgt werden
bislang galt das ziel für die drei
großen etablierten netzbetreiber
mindestens 97 prozent der haushalte mit
50 mbit/s zu versorgen und zwar bis 2020
der erfolgreiche bieter mustern auch
dafür sorgen dass bis ende 2022 alle
bundesstraßen und autobahnen mit 100
mbit s versorgt sind
das wird wirklich eine absolute
revolution wir werden vollkommen neue
apps software und webseiten mit ziemlich
ausgeklügelten anwendung haben
ich bin schon extrem gespannt wenn ihr
kein video dazu zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann abonniert auch den
englischen weg zum kanal dafür einfach
hier klicken auch da gibt es die eine
oder andere video premiere
und da drunter geht's weiter einfach
draufklicken start extractor bmw kam zu
reality objects kampflos so stay tuned